you've always said that to me since I've
met you and obviously that's been the
journey that you're on right now that
this phase in your life is giving back
and sharing the principles you've
learned have you always had a vision for
different stages of your life and I
don't mean a five-year 10-year plan I
mean more of like this is the world I'm
walking into like is that how you I
would say I don't know how many years
ago I started to realize the Arc of life
right there's actually an exercise in
the book on the Larkin life that's New
York in life yeah and these are all the
different things that happen to you at
that stage it's almost like a script and
by going down this script one can see
where one is and one could see the
things that are going to come at them I
started to realize that in a big picture
pit I don't know maybe it was 45 30
years ago I can't say but then I began
to research it and understand it a lot
greater and then I began to feel it
you feel it again when you can connect
intellectually what's happening with
subliminally and emotionally what's
happening to you you gain perspective
and so this like this phase
um it's not just an intellectual thing I
don't know maybe Nature has programmed
us in our minds to have these needs and
feelings at certain age so I know that
now like the greatest joy that I can
have is to help people be successful
without me I mean I know what my time
Horizon is and I know that my greatest
joy is not any longer in being
successful myself
um that was that that was great and it's
fine and so on but I don't need more of
that and I really my greatest joy is in
helping other people and I can't say
whether that is a instinctual how much
of it's instinctual how much it's
cerebral by seeing that state age in
life but it's it's apparent